по бічних і Тетяні буде що
харчування було знайти кетаміне країни
бурі харчування в цій книзі буде
організовувати праведного фахівці
відео до свічки цій гілці української
центру ціни яскравості координатор
міжнародного до побачення томів я
закриваю журналісту вузлуватий харчування на
дельпане місці чиновнику дали я вже
слухає і нагрітого нараду я вище
вистачило pattern та від краси що моя
україна та наша система вас ветошкіна та
не посипаючи йому голову по балу
що у нас я дуже багато душевний і з
показала наш прогрес у kenshi там
пішов ременя інакше результати бірж
його ким су та інший тим суми
просунулась а в парі наша проблема і
чому я прогнозу view що далі
покращувати СНІД може стати таким стартом
ти ми плачем багата проблем які кути в
valyria в тому, щоб поки що наше
мовчання у школі орієнтована на
репродукцію знати на цілий гвинта ванної
та знизу зовнішнього на закладеного
оцінювання так-то м'яз за зовнішнім газом
лижного києва не вигляд дзеркалі це
покращувати школі і нам поки що школі вчать
чому хочемо, що вимагає на цьому вони і
там уми розряду йому пізу
я графік 1 ст вже корисливих інструментів
для нас я таки йдучи в системі
оцінювання та системі змі стільця та в суміші
його свити минулого ти найдаків bad
and не знову підходу в на вч вони там у я
теж піднімаються що це буде довідки
взаємовигідно спить брати і ми з вами
стоїмо на порозі сил із прямого нам уру
ху з реформування sweet це заради
блага
наших українських дітей явну поклику
я ким че я , у журналістів покинув
я думаю що я